your brothers and sisters in islam net
from norway are establishing a masjid a
dawa center
this center this masjid this educational
institution will act like a beacon of
light calling the muslims in norway back
to the essence of islam so give
generously and allah azzawajal will give
you even more
assalamu alaikum
how are you guys doing
i'm joined with fahad from islam net you
may be familiar with some of the
advertisements that we've been doing for
islam net
trying to raise money for
the dawa center which we'll maybe talk
about a little bit later on in norway
it's one of its kind it's a very
important establishment which master
muslims need to contribute to
but today we want to get started maybe
with
the recent events that took place
with the stabbing of salman rushdie
now as a leader of an organization
fahad
and as a muslim of course
do you condemn this action that was
being inspired by the fatwas of 19
whenever it was in 79 whenever the hell
it was
do you condemn that
our stance on this matter is clear and
it's always been clear that we are not
encouraging violence we do not encourage
anyone to act in this way we believe
that every muslim should abide by the
laws and do whatever they can according
to the prophet if you care if you see a
moon you change it with your hand and if
you can't then you change it with your
mouth so
obviously
our role here as muslims in the west
would be to change
or speak out against these vile
insults that this individual has come
with against the prophet saws against
the wives of the prophet
it's right to mention that you know
first of all i think there's a lot of
kind of cutting and pasting going on
there's a lot of going into history and
classical books of jurisprudence islamic
jurisprudence
where you know certain fat words have
been given maybe a thousand years ago
um about the blasphemy laws and so on
which by the way are a matter of
difference of opinion this is something
which
mentions quite clearly
of uh
there's a very famous
uh hadith of the prophet muhammad where
in bahadis mentioned that he's walking
with his wife and some jews came to him
the hostile individuals they were who
said to him assalamu alaikum
death be upon you
and he was wonder and then responded his
wife responded in a very
elaborative way and then he stopped at
the prophet muhammad we said that
you know just
just say walaikum you know just saying
upon you
and then he he went into a discussion
about an ethical discussion he said that
that there was nothing there was not
goodness in anything in fact it was
removed
of course that that would uh
that if it was in it if kindness and
gentleness was in that thing
that it would beautify and if it was
removed from it it would make it ugly
and a very
similar hadith of the prophet muhammed
some individuals
from quraish the pagan arabs at the time
were attacking the prophet calling him
within them calling him the dispraised
one
and he responded by um
by saying that
uh
they are attacking this individual
called them they dispraised one and i'm
muhammad i'm the praised one
they so in other words there is some
legitimacy in in saying that when the
prophet
the way he would deal with insults
wasn't a narcissistic control way it was
a very controlled and strategic manner
where if it had an impact on the polity
and the particular situation at a time
then a harsh action would be taken yes
but if it didn't it would a harsh action
would not be taken he wasn't faced he
hand-waved this whole situation off
but of course someone will say well
there are classical opinions they even
tell wrote a whole book called the sun
rasool
and that the unsheathed sword on the the
one who insults the prophet and so on
and
so many people in different schools of
thought have spoken about the capital
punishment for those who attack
the prophet muhammad assault him
but this is taking something which is
abstract the abstract hokum and trying
to apply it on uh today so that
the real truth is that even tamiya
himself the same person who wrote this
book
as well as um you know the scholars of
today
don't just look at
acam or rulings in abstraction this
manner what they do is they look at the
ruling in conjunction with the reality
around them and that's why you'll find
that in relation to this matter of
blaspheming
uh
in western lands like ours and you know
where there's you know laws and places
on
the main the major centers of islamic
power have uh maintained that actually
there's a great master or detriment a
communal detriment into like you said
you know trying to challenge the law in
this in this vigilante way
and so we would say that when they ask
us about
the condemnation of this kind of uh
thing of individual doing this kind of
things but we do so on the basis of
sharia consequently quite frankly sharia
consequentialism that is to say the cost
benefit analysis and that's a fine
ethical standard actually one that the
whole of philosophical liberalism is
based on it unless of course we're
looking at immanuel kant's type of uh
social um liberalism but the the point
is therefore it can be condemnable on
the basis of breach of the peace
uh on the basis of mafsa detriment
on the basis of this is something which
is a barrier to entering the tower on
the basis that this is something which
threatens the muslims it can be
condemned in all those bases and we do
condemn it and that's not our strategy
it's not our way
in dealing with individuals that insult
the prophet
the the very purpose of salman rushdie
writing his book is to diminish the
religion of islam diminish the the
truthfulness of the prophethood of the
prophet saw sallam and now his book is
has become a bestseller it's an amazon
bestseller so his lies about the prophet
saws his insults to the prophet saws
wives are now just being spread when
someone does these kinds of acts this
taking the law in their own hands it
actually goes against the very purpose
of
making the religion of islam prevail and
and and giving dawa to to do these kinds
of acts so that's why i say that we need
to think wisely how we respond to people
like this how we respond to people who
are insulting the dean of allah or
burning the quran insulting the prophet
and that's why if we look at this guy in
norway he's burning the quran and he's
been doing that
for so many times now we used this
individual as a useful idiot
for the cause
[Laughter]
we have been able so we
as you know bro and as we as you also
said in the beginning that
we're building this machine
we are raising funds to establish the
first of its kind masjid and our center
in the whole country of norway
and through this guy we have raised over
dollars for building this message
so if we you if we use this for this
individual this is a strategic approach
which in advances the islamic cause is
that we've used this individual who has
been trying to attack the muslim
community and in a project where we're
trying to build a mosque which will be
the biggest and the dawah center which
will be the biggest in this kind in the
whole of scandinavia he's helped us
raise half a million
dollars is it
yeah
so
that's
that's amazing isn't it maybe maybe
someone maybe salman rushdie
can help us raise some more
exactly bro tell us a little bit about
this project just because some people
watching this may not know about what
project this is in just a nutshell
before we look at the
interactions you've had with this
individual
all right so we are establishing a one
of its kind masjid and community center
at dawa center in the whole country of
norway it will inshallah have a
playground for kids to nurture love for
the dean of allah it would have it will
have like a gym where people can come
and work out it would have dawah
facilities it would have classrooms an
educational institution that would be
teaching
the community about the dean of allah
something which is absolutely
unheard of in the country of norway we
don't have any single islamic community
center or dawah center with these kinds
of facilities we don't even have we
don't have we don't even have like
islamic schools in the way do we that's
true we don't have a single islamic
school in the whole country so we need
to establish these kinds of institutions
in the country of norway and we are
starting off with this uh we've called
it iman activity center so it will be a
center that would build the iman of our
children
and the link for this project is in the
description box and the comment section
below correct exactly it would be there
they'll click it and it'll be a quick
one isn't it it will take two seconds uh
maybe what ten seconds for them to to
put the payment through
exactly it would take just a few seconds
and and the
that that
that's really what we should be talking
about that's why muslims are always on
the back foot this is a way we can
actually start being on the front foot
correct
a hundred percent bro so we need to use
these kinds of individuals
just for just for promoting the islamic
cause because that will burn them up
so
so look they're going to get blown up as
well in the hellfire
i mean let's be honest about it
but talking about the hellfire and
people are going to burn up therein
let's let's look at some of the
reactions that let's let's react to some
of your videos that you've had with this
interview let's look at the the vile
nature of this human being okay let me
show you this one video where this guy
when he comes to our our property and
he's there to burn the quran and we
confront him and then he starts to swear
at the prophet sallam now obviously
i could have done what
this guy did and just you know go crazy
and attack him
if i had done that
and
it would have damaged the cause of islam
so instead of doing that i just
responded to his insults and then used
this guy to raise money to benefit the
dean of allah let's take a look at the
video please
well i mean there you have it i mean so
you didn't pull out a knife and start
stabbing the man did you no exactly
that's not our way
but at the same time we can't just stand
there except that he's insulting the
prophet saws and saying these
vile uh disgusting things about the
thing is i mean as you've correctly said
it just won't serve the cause as as well
yeah you know it just won't serve the
chords as well as simple as that
and and this is a great example of an
individual who's
i think your strategy has been
impeccable i think you've used these
individuals
to the service of islam as you've
mentioned this individual has helped us
raise
half a million
dollars i mean
stabbing him or hurting him or
annihilating him or doing whatever you
want to do won't be as useful with it
honestly it would just make him a hero
look look
so they made him into this icon of
freedom of speech
and what in reality he's just a filthy
man
but they made him an icon of freedom of
speech why should we give him that honor
that status rather we should use him to
serve the dean of allah so let's just
make the final appeal here brothers and
sisters everyone was watching yes please
let's take action right now whenever
these guys are honored and venerated for
their vile
disgusting insults against the prophet
sallam
we should respond by giving tawa and
supporting tawa and establishing the
islamic institutions whenever any anyone
of you donates for this noble cause you
will be sharing in the reward of
responding back to these
interests against the prophet salallahu
against the burning of the quran you
would actually be defending the deen of
allah by doing this don't you agree i
agree and i like the fact that we're
using them not just
now
by spreading awareness of what the
religion of islam actually is because a
lot of people that
you know they hear these things about
muslims understand they don't even know
what islam is they don't even know the
basic tenets
but that now we're using them for our
own purposes
as the muslim community so it can raise
funds for our future generations i think
it's a fantastic strategy and i'm that's
why i'm for it do not forget to give
that kind of charity to to propel our
calls forward and to make the muslims
and the word of islam uppermost by
clicking the link below
when the son of adam dies
all of his good deeds are interrupted
they are finished
except for three things
a continuous charity and a beneficial
knowledge and also a righteous offspring
that makes dua for him your brothers and
sisters in islam net from norway are
establishing a masjid a daowa center and
fulfilling a great portion of this
hadith on your behalf establishing a
masjid to convey the message of islam is
one of the best deeds a muslim can do
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada
in the masjid whenever someone learns
something in the masjid
yes
that will be something that you will
have on your scale
so give generously and allah azzawajal
will give you even more
you